it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week's a little thin on games
but you could always use this extra time
to catch up on work and family
no wait super time force is coming out
we're saved now you can play and play
and play without any regard for any
other aspect of your life gray the
side-scrolling bullet hell shooter
follows a time-traveling military
organization to prehistoric times to
save the dinosaurs from extinction
that sounds awesome and you almost spent
time with your family also this week
minecraft is back and coming to retail
on the ps3 notch has really come a long
way since that tick post five years ago
hopefully it spawns more incredible
creations like Lannisport created by
Westeros craft or this BioShock Infinite
Matt Bai I like two people or a working
16-bit computer biome here's to another
five years of amazing creations start
building may 16 speaking of badass
blocks battle block theater is about to
wreak havoc on steam with
self-proclaimed that opinion Pete grab
and same rates up up to 21,000 per
minute seconds and they're also quite
keen on telling you about frozen do
justice I really have to do anything for
this video battle block comes out May 15
and finally relive your glory days in
pandora with the retail PS vita version
of Borderlands 2 can't wait for the
pre-sequel to get in on the gun hoarding
treasure-seeking psycho smashing fun
grab up all the iridium you can carry
with the latest Vita port that tosses in
6 add-on packs to keep you busy until
you get to Pandora's moon to take on the
younger but still evil handsome Jack
start cross saving hopefully May 13th
for further details visit GameSpot's new
releases page release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change see you next week